[Music]
[Applause]
jump force is a new crossover fighting
game which features anime characters
from shounen jump which is a magazine
that contains tons of manga that has
introduced the world to things like
Dragon Ball Z or rurouni kenshin Naruto
one piece this is a major major thing
and it's sort of like Super Smash
Brothers except for anime something I
was really excited about actually
despite some initial fears when I saw
the character designs in 3d which was a
little strange I have to admit this game
was developed by Spike Chunsoft and
published by Bandai Namco entertainment
the main story begins when Frieza is
fighting with some of the heroes and
he's destroying things and a civilian
gets affected by a blast and this
civilian is revived by trunks and the
new play is that civilian you can
customize your avatar with various
things which we'll talk about in a
second then you're introduced to the
lobby where there's online and offline
matchmaking there shops there's upgrade
abilities and then you have to choose a
team and these teams are made up of
specific characters from Shonen Jump
manga and you can choose which ones you
like based off of the people who are in
the team whether or not you have certain
favorites like I chose team alpha
because Goku is there and you know I'm a
giant Dragon Ball fan or you can choose
a team based off of skill set which I
couldn't blame you for not really
knowing what that even means since the
game just started and you know nothing
about it
then there's a long list of missions you
can complete some of them are training
some of them do factor into the story
there's a lot of cutscenes let's talk
about those cutscenes because now we're
gonna get into the nitty-gritty this
game was fucking terrible the idea of
taking these characters that are so
famous in drawing and in animation form
and turning it into 3d animation could
potentially be a great idea
unfortunately the animation for these
characters especially their facial
expressions completely laughable they
rarely change from this very stern look
of anger Goku is a character that's very
light hearted but throughout this entire
game he looks extreme
we mad and everyone else does and after
a few days of playing the game the
character animations the cutscenes the
extremely dumb enemy AI and some of the
rather impossible scenarios you get
yourself caught up in in the middle of
fights where you just lose half of your
health one the enemy does like an
extreme combo of specials all of this
became so funny that I invited my friend
over and we played the game well a
little bit inebriated some vodka may
have been involved man did that enhance
the experience let's talk about the
music for a second the music for the
lobby
sounds like a 1970s porn film it starts
out really good and then there's this
shift where it just becomes shaft
[Music]
shut up there's also a considerable
amount of technical glitches as well
little tiny things like my character's
feet not touching the ground my wife
actually pointed that out I made her to
look like my wife you know an
exaggerated anime version of her and
there was a time when I spawned in the
lobby and I was just surrounded by other
players lodged within them and I could
move through them as if they were ghosts
and there's various people placed
throughout the lobby that you can go up
to and speak to and sometimes they'll
give you advice or a helpful hint and
they all seem to be dressed like trunks
almost every single one of them and it
became so repetitive that it was just a
joke after a while like so much of this
game but let's talk about repetition for
a second because the fighting in the
game is really what should be the saving
grace the matches are they fun sometimes
yeah sometimes they can actually be a
lot of fun this game isn't like superman
64 level atrocious or disappointing the
character animations and the cutscenes
absolutely are but the fights can be
okay and online I encountered virtually
no lag which I was impressed by but
after a few days of a lot of matches the
fighting does get very repetitive once
you learn how to dash and sidestep and
sort of block properly and how to get
out of a block and some of the things
you can do to stop the enemy from doing
these insane combos that are just
unrealistically unfair once you learn
some of those things the fighting does
get better and I think is just like an
online fighting game purely this could
have some legs especially by patching
certain things namely load times
skipping cutscenes improving some of
these things which they have mentioned
they would like to do once that happens
I feel like the fighting can at least be
playable but man was it ever improved by
some vodka holy shit what a great night
I mentioned customizing your avatar
because it really sucks the amount of
options you have there's extreme limit
to them and most of the customizable
things are just clothing or hairstyles
from other anime characters from shown
and jump there's not that much
originality to it you can basically make
yourself look
kind of like other anime characters and
just customized a very small amount of
things
I don't normally review games that I
didn't like but in this case it was just
something I was really looking forward
to playing it was something I was
excited to get my hands on something
that I've waited for for a long time the
idea of this crossover event there are
other games that involve Shonen Jump
characters that are considerably better
namely this one which came out semi
recently was Dragonball Fighters this
was awesome this was really good also
published by Bandai Namco entertainment
considerably better I would recommend
this over jump force based off of what
I've played so far I would rate this
game a 4 out of 10 it could be improved
considerably with patches and a lot of
fixes and so I'm not gonna like give
this game like a hard rating you know
and I'm not gonna come back and rewrite
it again I mean if they patch things and
it gets better that's great but this
will be my one kind of thoughts on video
for jump force it annoys me that I have
to to give the game that caveat like it
could get better if they fix things
because I already paid $60 for it and
bought it it should be done like the
improvements that can be made should be
minimal at this point not these
drastically humongous changes that would
fix the game and that's the problem with
modern games in my opinion it's just so
much of them are released before they're
100% finished and this game does feel
unfinished and as someone who's waited
for the game for a while drastically
disappointing nevertheless guys thank
you so much as always for watching look
forward to more reviews very soon and if
you like this you can click right here
and get stuck mine eyes
[Music]